the jurogan experience i have a lot of
friends that uh they send me the green
text and every now and then one will
show up blue they give up and they jump
on the iphone train i'm like interesting
i can't do it man no why what is it
about it i
um because it's one of those things
where i'm so into my tech and [ __ ] yeah
and if you if i go iphone then i gotta
go apple everything
why
because because that's the that's the
whole advantage of going apple is that
it all just works together so well
because they're on their own little
ecosystem you know what's the advantage
of not going apple uh customization
oh okay but you
you're not are you using the phone with
other stuff does it integrate with other
stuff the way an iphone does because i
have a samsung phone samsung tablet
samsung watch
you know and if i go iphone then i gotta
get an apple watch i gotta get a ipad
you know what's better
um have you [ __ ] with apple stuff oh
yeah yeah yeah i used to i've had
iphones yeah but i just oh so you went
android after you on iphone i went i
went android iphone
android iphone android
oh see back and forth huh yeah i went
back and forth but at the end of the day
it was just like
i stuck with it because android is more
you know on top of like some of the
latest like apple won't do anything
unless they can do it
in a way where you where it goes oh
that's apple you know what i mean like
like the [ __ ] headphones right like
that they would they would not come out
with headphones until they could do
something where you like when you see it
you know that it's not something else
right you know it's an apple device
right same thing with the apple watch
that's why it's shaped weird it's
because yeah they want you to look at it
and go that's a that's an apple that is
true because the samsung one some dude
had one the other day on it looked like
a regular watch oh that's a dope watch
what is it he's like it's galaxy watch
and i thought it was a regular watch and
he goes no you can change the screen and
he's like [ __ ] within it but it was
round yeah yeah right
but it just looks like a watch
apple don't want that you know yeah
um but it but it i love i do love the
way all the apple [ __ ] works together
but it's like they call it a walled
garden yes everything's beautiful in the
garden but you try to do some [ __ ]
outside like hit like because and apple
does all these little
they do all these little shitty tactics
to facilitate that right so so the whole
green bubble
blue bubble thing that originally came
out like you remember back when you had
to pay for texts
no
yeah they used to charge for text
messages how much did they charge i
don't know it was like you know
five send a message or they would give
you a bundle or some would come with
your plan
and
and apple created
imessage
and the and green was supposed to
represent
a text that you paid for and blue was
supposed to be one that was free because
it was in the apple network
and then
right after they invented it it
that kind of went away there was no all
text messages are free but they noticed
that there was a little bit of that
there was this little snobbery did it
like so they purposely they could fix it
they could easily integrate
imessages so that it doesn't come up
different
but they won't because it it
it increases that fear of missing out
that makes people want to go [ __ ] i'm
just gonna get an iphone i'm tired of
being left out of the group chats
perfect example if you send me a video
it'll come up blurry yeah
right and that's that's an apple thing
it is yes but if you send a samsung guy
video will come out perfect
oh yeah if i if i send you a video it'll
come up perfect but if you send me one
it'll come up blurry really yeah because
they want me to feel left out and or
praise the person here's another example
you know how when you text somebody you
you uh they can react to it so it'll be
like a smiley face or whatever right so
up until recently
if
if i sent you a text and you and you
hearted it right
it would it would say to me
joe hearted and then it would give me my
whole text in quotes oh
and what does it do now well now
android's work has done like a little
work around so if that if you get a text
like that it'll just put a heart
underneath it okay so i'm gonna send you
one right now yeah and you'll get a
little heart all right here we go oh my
my shit's off no okay i forgot it yeah
but but they so they do they apple does
that on purpose because they want
you to put the pressure on your friends
to buy an iphone it's kind of smart it
is it's genius i'm not mad at before
they have no incentive to work together
with everybody else but isn't it also
that it's encrypted like imessages are
encrypted whereas like text messages or
not
um
yes that's true but that's that again
but that's something that they
they won't allow the encryption to be
shared you know
because here's the thing that's only a
thing in the u.s
everywhere else in the world
people use whatsapp and right right all
this other stuff whatsapp's giant
overseas oh it's huge it's huge and and
iphone is not the this is only well not
just only here but there's only one or
two countries where it's the number one
phone really yeah
that's interesting
i wonder why whatsapp and all those
other things i think it's because you
could use them over wi-fi and so you
could chat without using your minutes
right right you use them over wi-fi it's
encrypted it's all the things that come
with imessage it's its own platform do
you remember when um
roaming would cost you a [ __ ]
shitload of money yeah like if you used
your phone in connecticut you'd be
doomed i remember when you had minutes
yeah you had talk minutes yes and it's
like a lot of these kids don't get it
man it's pretty recent
yeah it's not that long i mean maybe no
more than
15 years ago was it that long ago
minutes yeah well yeah night and weekend
minutes you know 7 p.m opera your hours
are at nine ours are at seven well i
remember when i had because i used to
have singular which is i think they're
part of t-mobile now but they singular
used to be like if if if i called
another singular customer it didn't use
my minutes or if you called somebody
during certain hours it didn't use your
minutes
you know it was like peak hours and off
hours
yeah i remember that singular i remember
too
yeah and what's funny is it's the same
[ __ ] network
first they told us oh we have to charge
for minutes otherwise we would swamp the
network and now minutes are free and
then they start charging for texts
like it'll flood the network we've got
to charge for texas now texas free and
they're charging for data
and data they actually need i don't know
if they need to charge what they charge
you know whenever [ __ ] goes down and
everybody tries to use their phone you
can't use your phone ever that's what's
weird like try using your phone at a
sporting event like if you're at like a
super bowl or something like that yeah
it's impossible everybody's using their
phone well try calling somebody
somewhere where just something happen an
earthquake or something right yeah it's
a wrap they won't work no and then that
wild like
if they have a million customers like
save a self song just as an example just
for a number they don't have to have a
million lines available at all times no
they should they should treat them like
casinos
like you have to have x amount of
dollars
for every person that's in the casino
right in case they win yeah because
could they accommodate everybody like
there has to be
250 million phones in this country
minimum minimum yeah probably more yeah
probably as many as there are people
right yeah but if everybody wanted to
call at the same time like what's the
number that it can hold
[ __ ]
i don't know is it local because it's
like local breakers or local
i mean how does that work do you know
how it works
really it's wild because
there's different technologies on
different networks right it's 4g and
there's 5g no no no i mean like cdma
versus i forget what the other one is
but like verizon gsm right yeah gsm
right and so they so
and i want to say i think we're the only
country the only western country that
where it's split that way like
you know like if you go to korea it's
all one technology i think they all use
gsm yeah i think um what correct me if
i'm wrong about this too i think cdma
it works better deep inside of buildings
i'm not sure i'm not sure i think that
was the the positive aspect and that's
only in this country verizon and sprint
right but we yeah well sprint just got
bought but just merged with t-mobile oh
yeah so it's getting smaller and at the
end of the day disney's gonna own
everything
they're gonna own every [ __ ] thing
man damn
you